[Musique]
dans les bagnoles aujourd'hui c'est la
poule qui conduit monsieur roule des
yeux de veau pendant qu'elle pilote ça
sacheevau il a l'air très embêté assis à
ses côtés et quand elle sert les freins
il sert autre chose sans un trin il lui
faut du courage lorsqu'elle prend ses
virage quand moi j'envois à un
croisement du bois qui font sur moi
vivement je ne l'engueule pas mgalement
je lui fais pouette-pouette elle me fait
pouettepouette on se fait pouet pouette
et puis ça y est je souris pouette
pouette elle sourit pouette pouette on
sourit pouette pouette on s'est
compris alors le monsieur qui me voit
fait une sele
trempette il y en a même quelquefois qui
d'un quiir Rous P je lui fais pouette
pouette elle me fait pouettepouette on
se fait po de poette et pu ça y est
jadis on se faisait la cour avant de
parler d'amour ça durait trop longtemps
rien que sur la pluie et le beau temps
ce n'était que le lendemain qu'on se
baisait la main et 15 jours après qu'on
s'embrassait d'un peu plus frais moi
quand une femme m'excite j'y vais
beaucoup plus vite mon regarde setard
lui plisant qu' un coup de poignard je
lis au fond de ses yeux j'en dis pas
ça vaut bien mieux je lui fais pouette
pouette elle me fait pouette pouette on
se fait pouette pouette et puis ça y
est je souris pouet pouette elle sourit
pouette pouette on sourit pouê pouette
on s'est compris et quand je lui ai bien
chanté ma petite romance
elle dit d'un enchanté jeais
recommence je fa pouette pouette elle
fait pouette pouette on sen FA ou et pu
ça y est je luiou
[Musique]
on
se